à à
anh alo cho bạn
ờ ờ
Anh
vừa mới mở máy mà đã thấy cặp sách à ok
Ừ rồi ờ ờ
à mà vài cái câu hỏi đây Tôi nghĩ là
phải đến vài buổi khi mà đến cái bài
đăng cụ thể hòa nhập đến cái ví dụ cụ
thể tôi sẽ tôi sẽ trả lời cho mấy hôm
sau nhá Tôi có nốt lại đây em chuyển tôi
sẽ trả lời luôn nhé bởi vì có vài cái
thì tôi trả lời chắc là cho là
mấy ông cũng khó hình dung đấy Nếu không
hiểu thì thôi à
Ừ mạng thi bố hôm nay mình sẽ làm là
thì thật này đấy à
cho bộ mày mình sẽ làm là mình sẽ lấy à
à
chưa làm xong rồi đăng nhập cơ tôi nghĩa
là đăng nhập và đăng nhập mình sẽ dùng
season như mình không dùng lao nữa
hồ bơi bị đau chân máy tôi không ngờ nó
không chạy được Nó không biết được nói
trên trên khi mà đẩy lên hốt thì nó sẽ
như thế nào nhưng mà trên máy tôi có về
không chạy được vào đấy thì cứ để tạm
season cũng được đây các bạn ơi nó tương
tự giống nhau đương nhiên về sau mình
dùng những cái Pocket mà liên quan mình
có nhau nữa thì mình phải con thích
nhưng cái đấy tính sau vậy
mà mạnh riêng em ạ Nhưng mà thường thì à
Vì sao mình có một tí kiến thức về Seo
để mình tối ưu cho trang web của mình
thì càng tốt ở trong ngành Công nghệ
thông tin này thì ở biết thêm một tí
kiến thức nó không mở cửa cả Đó là giống
như kiểu học lập trình cho biết thêm 12
khủng thứ để bảo mật không sao là đừng
có đi phá nhà người ta đúng nhưng nói
chung là đại khái thì ngày công nghệ pin
này nó rỡ 2 vừa là yêu vừa nói nhiều và
như thế lắm chị ạ Không đủ kiến thức nào
thừa và những chính mình như thế thành
ra là quá nhiều thứ thực sự là nếu mình
muốn làm chủ kia mùa 5 chủ đề ông ạ em
làm chủ công nghệ và cái gì đó muốn anh
Master hyper fashional cái gì đó đều ra
là một con người cầu toàn học cái ngành
này nó sẽ rất là bị quá tải Bởi vì bởi
vì có thằng Tỉ thứ cần phải học và công
nghệ còn thay đổi nó nâng cấp thay đổi
và Vân liên tục nên này ra là kéo rất
khó để mà mình chạy theo được nên là
mình phải nộp giúp mình mình chỉ cần đến
ngưỡng đó rồi Mày đặt cùng mốc đấy Nhưng
lỡ rồi
cũng không nên ăn phận quá nhưng mà cũng
đừng nên ham quá nhiều người tham quá
rồi chết
nụ hôn nào lấy người mà rủ
biết được xác định rõ mục tiêu đúng
không ạ
ở
ý ông là như thế nào nhỉ
ít nhất là hỏi tôi về thầy Tám rồi hơn
một lông thì tôi không lành thật toàn
lắm
cái búa hay thư viện nào Đĩa
Ừ Ông học nghề mô hình mvc đã nếu mà ông
muốn làm kiểu Bác en ê
thức hoạt động nó như thế nào á Ờ nó sẽ
kiểu chạy
kiểm tra điều kiện theo từng lòng mà nhi
Ừ thôi không biết được cơ chế đấy Thật
tạm gì nữa à
có
nên cho người que đấy đôi khi nó sẽ ưu
tiên
cái đấy bài toán em phải chạy thêm
explain là nó trước select Để xem nó bản
chất sẽ dùng cái gì nó sẽ ưu tiên là
trước
ừ ừ
cũng chỉ biết mới biết mơ hồ rồi chứ
Không làm chắc được
làm với cho đó là ờ
các bạn Trăng làm gì đó mỗi đồng ngôn
ngữ đâu mà Thế hôm nay mình sẽ làm là
mình sẽ đầu tiên là khi mà thay đổi cái
này chẳng hạn ở đâu có tên là mình phải
liệt kê toàn bộ Cái ở đây đã toàn bộ như
gái bên này mà mình sẽ cách lại để mình
hiểu ra xử là cái trong vòng 24 giờ để
mình đỡ phải cứ load lại ở trong bê cái
mình Mình sẽ lưu lại cái gì Mình sẽ lưu
lại là ở những cái bài đăng này nó
thường ấy thường là sẽ lưu lại là những
cái bài đăng này
Ừ Đợi thì đợi tí
À nhầm Lá Me Bay
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
là lấy thông tin từ bài đăng sau đó thì
lọc trùng sau đó đi đổ ra cái phần này
để làm gì Để khi mỗi khi mình Peter thì
chắc chắn là sẽ có vài năm là sử sẽ xử
thế còn hay là mình cứ có sẵn một cái bộ
phim tơ không quan tâm có bài này Không
thực ra là tôi hơi khó chịu ở cây mới
phải trang web mà làm như thế thật Ôi da
xử nó hiển thị ở đây là Hà Nội Hồ Chí
Minh Đà Nẵng thể hạ tôi ấn ở Đà Nẵng cứ
gồng chả ra cái bà đâu rồi các bạn Thực
ra tôi khó chịu khi điểm đấy Hiền lên là
nếu mà để dễ chịu hơn một tí về cái vụ
đấy thì nên hiển thị số lượng của Ngài
đấy có sẵn cũng được nhưng mà đương
nhiên làm thêm tốn hơn câu truy vấn nên
thường mà cũng tùy từng nơi làm thế
nhưng mà đã rẽ và méo hiểu Không hiểu
thì bị ra có rất nhiều thịnh hành ở đây
chẳng hạn đúng không ấn vào tỉnh nào
cũng thấy trống người ra ấn hai lần
người ta thử chống người gợi chán rồi
chẳng hạn thế đúng ạ ý tưởng thầy Triệu
thế đấy Cuối cùng thì nó chỉ có mỗi Sài
Gòn thôi thằng Hà Nội không vào luôn tất
cả Tỉnh hiển thị ở đây nó bấm thằng nào
nó cũng chống muỗi Sài Gòn mình có thì
chồng lớn là buồn cười đúng ạ
I hear nếu mà làm theo kiểu bài đăng thì
tốt nhưng bài đăng thì sẽ phải lọc trùng
những thông tin
tỉnh có những thứ tập trung thì
Ê
mày có hiểu rồi nó sẽ cho lấy thông tin
toàn bộ City rồi à
Ừ từ bài đăng ra xong rồi lập trung để
một cách để một cách bé thứ hai đó là
mình sẽ lấy tự cầm một ly này lọc theo
tuổi khamenei dọc theo cái gì nữa nhỉ À
anh đọc theo ngôn ngữ chẳng hạn thế à
Thế thì sẽ lọc theo ạ
Anh thường là mình sẽ bây giờ mình sẽ có
lọc theo
à à Mimax e-reward còn gì nhỉ remote này
lại nói chung là những cái ở trong cái
35 có cái gì mình sẽ lấy ra để lọc Chả
thế à
này chết bốc này nghe giá này
tệ rồi tiền tệ thời gian đó khá nằm ở
điểm là ra xử là
bộ lọc heo tiền vào này nó rất là khó
nếu ở mình quý ông mặc định ở đô la
quyết thẳng luôn ha cốt là đô la nó lại
dễ chân Nếu mà là sử mà bây giờ đang để
chồng như này xong rồi quy ước ra là
tiền là do mình nhập vào trong b là Việt
Nam đồng thời hạ thì có nè mình nó sẽ
không đúng nữa
béo hiểu ý cho ông trừ khi mình phải
nhân vật cái giá ở đây kết hợp với đôla
thì ra tiền lệ chuẩn
ừ nếu thế thì mình có thể có cơ chế đó
là ở đây mình sẽ khó có nở đôla nha là
sự thế sau đó mình sẽ lưu lại tỷ giá ở
trong trong tao bây vậy ở trong cốt vậy
sự nếu mà thường xuyên gọi lên api để mà
lấy tỷ giá dừa cũng được cũng được công
ty cũ Cẩm Ly Hiện tại tôi cũng làm chỗ
đấy Nó gọi lên một cái ipi thường xuyên
để lấy tỷ giá Nhưng đấy đó hả Cái trang
thương mại điện tử thì nó phải luôn cập
nhật tỷ giá đúng con mình tỷ giá ước
lượng là một cái phạm trù cũng được rồi
chứ khi về sau có vấn đề gì đó với tỷ
giá thôi
thôi
chị đã toàn bộ đấy nha đầu tiên thì mày
toàn bộ tình này
remote nhỉ
Cái phải sợ lại này tính đến sau
các tỉnh thì mình sẽ phải à
để cho phép chỗ à
Ừ nếu mà tất cả những lời đều biết tắt
rồi còn nếu không mua là không biết tắt
2 tất cả cùng không biết tắt đi tất cả
cũng không biết tắt cho chọn đi
I had a bên này đang đang tới bây giờ
ờ ờ từ cái cái file file của mình đúng ạ
Mình sẽ sửa lại cái file mình
em nhập vào tôi bây giờ chuẩn đã
trong dot lúc mà mình khi mà mình in sốt
vào hôm trước thì nó lại thành phi
thường và có những cái khác thì mình lại
không viết tắt nhiều dụng nghĩ là nên
thống nhất là không biết tắt nó sẽ ổn
hơn
ạ Và ở đây mình đang làm đó là
theo rosie kiểu như này thì vẫn chất là
một cái bài đăng này không chúa người
này hỗ trợ người này tỉnh thành không ạ
mà kiểu ngay thì mình sẽ lọc và à mình
sẽ
em kiểm tra là anh thôi
các clip cái này City dạng 255 có biết
về sau có nhiều tỉnh thành nỗi ở quá rồi
Cái này không phải phải sao không chuyện
đấy
em nói chồng à Nếu thế cái nhập vào thì
mình sẽ phải bởi vì Giả sử giờ xử file
mình có sẵn như này rồi mình có thể sửa
lại cái đoạn Lúc mày import vào đi Vợ
sửa lại đoạn khi mi Porsche và sẽ hợp lý
hơn
ở đây
a City ai dùng mạng City mình à ở địa
điểm
a
City company
này đi đá coi ngựa chưa có ngồi yên sót
lại cho mày không xem
Anh Hải đừng quên đăng pha nhà xóa file
trước rồi
Vì sao mày đang này
anh xóa có money cũng được Cũng money
mấy cái này nó cũng là anh tính mà chúng
gọi xóa này
ừ ừ
Anh liên Uzi nữa
gia trên rồi kệ
ừ ừ
à à à
à à
à à quên quên quên
Delete from other
xóa nhiều quá treo chết
em chọn đi
Ừ Ok rồi đấy
ờ ờ language mới kệ đi nó mới có thêm
nghĩ nhiều nó hơi sai đấy cứ kệ đi
Em hãy nhiều phải bỏ qua
ở các tự động xóa hết cả ngày đi
số trang web có liên quan đến á
Cơ Học Chất language
anh
nhìn nhá nhìn vào tôi à in sẽ lại nha
City ở đây như mình đã nói thì bản chất
là địa điểm đây có hiện à Nó cách nhau
bởi dấu phẩy ngoại nó hên xui nhiều thì
mình sẽ là cho City ở đây sẽ đổi hình
như thế này đi à
Ừ ừ
sau đó đi ờ
ở đây tôi sẽ thường đặt tên là string
như này City giới thiệu được nó là nhiều
và đây mình sẽ là ây city
không thôi cứ để đây City theo cậu là
Slow như thế này thằng luôn vậy
chỉ cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy này
thì nó sẽ biến thành ma
nó mình lại có mỗi mạc toàn bộ City rồi
tiếp theo đó là
mình sẽ phải duyệt qua cái mạng này để
tôi muốn đổi chữ Hà Nội là chữ Hồ Chí
Minh ra sửa số không muốn đổi trong font
này hạn chế nên đổi trong tay xịn mà
mình sẽ làm như nhà mình sẽ đổi Mình sẽ
kiểu à
em đổi Hà Nội thành chữ hà nội viết
Hương Nói chung mình đổi trong cốt điều
kiện lên béo hiểu thì thôi không phải
tắt hương thứ remote này nên đi Mode thì
mình sẽ
a City này có nhiều hơn để chóng rồi
mình là nó không
thì sẽ như này
đi bây lại phải sửa lại đó bây cho phép
City trống sau đó thì à
em chẳng biết nhiều này cái gì để xem
lại nhé
I get Tôi nhớ không lầm nè cái này nó
anh nhiều đúng là nhiều nơi thật nghĩa
nhiều lắm chỉ là nó là nên đi nhiều cũng
là nôn đi Ghi mốt cũng là luôn này
ý nghĩa là
anh nhiều nhiều Ok Ok nó luôn Ok chờ đợi
chờ để đợi tí tôi hiểu tôi thích đoạn
này nhá
ở đầu tiên thì toàn bộ váy này mình sẽ
đổi lại ghi đè lên mình agrimart à
cách vẽ mình sẽ chạy vòng lập qua từng
Hằng à
- Xuân Mai
à à
ở đây sẽ
ít
từng Hằng
ừ ừ
từ
Ừ Thì đi Tôn I
vì tôi nghĩa cho vòng cho xích cày đây
nó dễ đi ích này
nếu nó bằng Hà Nội
mình sẽ ghi tên chữ hà nội
nó hiểu đâu
a tiếp theo
nữa nó remote
thì
mình sẽ trả về nó là
thì mình sẽ phải à
khi đôi tông tính giá đỡ tâm lý nhé
tôi sẽ phải vòng là phối kiểu đây rồi
đấy ạ
xin lỗi tội lỗi tôi ở đây sẽ là mạng này
hai tay mà thông tin này sẽ đặt tên này
erct vậy ạ
mà Tại sao tôi muốn loại bỏ cái trường
hợp và hiệu remote thì mình sẽ bỏ cái
phần tử đi
à à
Ừ
nếu nó là như thế này
thì mình sẽ à
cho
Android
cho nó như này
Em chuyển vào nhưng
à à
Ừ tôi có bài toán này đơn giản hơn này
vợ tôi nói cái này đơn giản hơn nhiều
này à
à à
ờ ờ
thẳng luôn này đi
đầu tiên thì
là Nhi
trường hợp này thì nó không thể dùng
trong lò vi hiểu rồi không ạ Nếu nó là
nhiều ngắm thế ạ Ok
Nếu nó là nhiều thì mình sẽ là cho hỏi
City là noni I
anh nghe này tôi ở cho nó trống bỏ qua
luôn và mình sẽ
bằng remote
a report inbox mở đúng không ở đây
bằng phone
Nhưng ở đây sẽ trong trường hợp này nó
sẽ bằng chú
đó như thế này
Ừ để mình có thể cho phép là có thể Uy
11 Apple này
remote I
à à
a boss vay một ít
bộ remote only này à
à à
ở nhà sẽ Office only đi Chẳng hạn hệ
hoặc dynamike tùy ý nghĩa Office only
trong trường hợp này mình sẽ là
ờ ờ
à à
ở Tuy nhiên mình thể sửa này sau nhé
hình ảnh như này
Em chỉ là nô này thì Zalo này
à
khi nó chuyển toàn bộ City vào trong này
thì
mình sẽ có một mảnh mới city mới là nó
sẽ lấy ý á Hà Nội Hồ Chí Minh trở về như
này
Ừ Ok tôi tôi thấy đoạn này vẻ ổn Đấy mà
Đây mình sẽ
bộ remote
có bồ
em sửa lại cái tên biến này đi remote
cái bồ đây
A và remote Apple II
City này Bây giờ nó sẽ làm mảng trong
chung Nó có thể vừa lùn vừa là Mạc thì
nếu mà trong trường hợp là
a Company ở đây
a City ở đây ở không được trống Đúng rồi
city không nên trống
kỹ thuật cho chồng đi
anh có thể chồng đi
ở đây sẽ là
à à
giới đoạn này không biết phích nó có bị
lỗi gì không nhỉ
Anh
tên Phát
em có hạt test ở đây
Ý mình là sốt là
cho city là bằng luôn
Vì sao phối cửa đây chắc không được chắc
không được
thôi nha à
à à
Uh cho nó sẽ báo lỗi em à City là nun
thì nó sẽ không
cho mày luôn thì nó sẽ hỏi tôi đang muốn
lắp phối ở đây có My name Mini mình Đây
là duy nhất City
nhà mình không lưu lại City ở trong
Company rồi nhỉ
trong
anh ở trong này đi nghỉ cho nhẹ
ở nhiệt độ phải lưu lại cái điều đấy
trong này
nhà mình có lưu lại Atlat thì bỏ luôn
đấy Hay đi mình nhưng lại mua Atlas thôi
cho người dùng muốn nhập gì nhập vào
trong cái này
mọi thông tin liên hệ mấy ngày thứ là
không quan trọng lắm không có trọng lắm
ừ ừ
Đưa bồ đi được tôi sẽ chạy Mai xin sửa
lại có lãi này tí
à à
ý
kiến học sinh giỏi ở sinh viên bị địt
lôi Á có nhiều hơn nhiều cái dit lon
miễn phí mà em cha cái ra đấy
mm enter
Ờ Ờ
mình sẽ ăn tơ 23 bà mà có money sẽ ra ăn
tơ
ở Kon Tum
anh em thuê bảo ở cách viết chỗ ngồi cho
nó rất dài nhưng thực ra phía sau mình
sẽ Cần lại
em PT này thì về sau mình cha nó tên bảo
kết nối phải tên cột cũng sẽ ra gì nữa
Company
fable II
tai nghe bị giật á Các bạn khác nó bị
héo
với mấy ông
cha mẹ ông thích thì mày không thể vào
xem luôn à
à à
đề thi thoảng nó bị quay quay á
anh Mạnh tôi tôi thấy hiện tại tôi Thực
ra tôi không thường xuyên quay sang bên
này không biết mạnh ổn định ơi Không là
Ừ có gì mày Ông cứ bảo rồi nhé I
ô tô du hạng mấy cụ lại đi nó hẳn à
Express
chị sẽ là
kiểm tra luôn mấy ông luôn nên kiểm tra
xem mà có tồn tại không
cái bộ làm sao chưa kiểm tra tồn tại
nhưng mà cứ chạy thôi
a Company này ở đây Air Blade 2 này à
đã sửa ngay à
Anh xóa rồi đi đây
em kiểm tra luôn ngay cho mày đi
nếu mà có này Xóa đây tiếp theo Nếu có
đi ship đây
à mà nếu có City Xóa hết đi
Ê thằng nữa
ở đó là
i m m
enter Blues
a city
in post
the first sneijder Watch
ông thầy bồ à
ở Huế thấy ông Khi mà kiểu một cái dự án
nó lên flash nó lên kiểu thực tế ơi thì
mấy ông ngồi sửa lại tao bay cũng có yêu
mình không phải cẩn thận và về nếu phải
tạo máy nói chuyện kiểu như này ờ
em lấy sẽ là
ở đây là
Em đang làm gì bossnight a tiếp theo là
City này à
cô gái livestream à
Ừ sáng nay đi này kiểm tra nếu có
Uh cho nó là luôn label
trên để mà thay đổi
Anh nói như thế này ok
ừ sáng mai của Xuân thôi
i m Mason rồi
Anh ta lại đây a City mình sẽ mất rồi
này
Xe tải tự nhiên là phải sửa lại
trong máy tí company
U60 nên ốp cột Như Lai
anh không hàn khuyến khích cổ group11
Google như này nha Ừ
nhạc
ở đây sẽ là City ở đây nó lại
mạnh đây
Ừ
rồi thiệt mạng ở đây sau đó thì à
có bị nhầm đấy thì nhớ Đợi tí nhé
đâu nhà nghỉ
ờ ờ
I
still này nếu nó là nhiều này thì
nó là remote
thì nói như này còn nếu nó như thế này
Ừ Vậy thì đợi tí nha mình sẽ có hàm ở
đây nhưng mà đội thẳng
nó là sẽ
bộ phim pre Plays
ở đây này
Ừ đúng nhỉ
Xin chào Phát
Ừ tôi Đùa đổi cái chỗ ấy trong chuỗi nó
sẽ kiểu như này à
tôi tôi sẽ ở nhà nhé
Ô thế không phải dùng hàng Play mà xinh
Player ừ ừ
Ừ thế như này à à em
nhớ có cái hàm để mà đổi
ăn chuối trồng chuối
Khi so sánh chuỗi với cái Android đồng
ngon tại Đại Hàn
cách chữa
ở Hồ Chí Minh thì sẽ đổi bằng ấy mạc như
này
ở Hà Nội
ở phố Hồ Chí Minh
nó như này sau đó thì mình sẽ
em chuyển City vào như này với thử cho
ông xem
có kết quả luôn nha
anh bắt chước nhưng ở bên này đi
Đây đúng ạ trả về kết quả cho mày không
Sao vậy
em có chịu đâu Đã đổi chữ này thành cái
chữ này Chữ này thì chuyện này ok
ở đâu nghĩ nhiều
em không cần phải yêu thằng này nữa
em võ si ti toàn bộ City sau đó City vào
trong ngày 11 Apple Ok Ok ste có thể nun
City thể nuôi Ok rồi đấy ạ
mày làm gì à Tôi đang kiểu cố làm cho nó
chuyên nghiệp để cho bé ông dễ hình dung
thôi
anh cho xem
cho AD về sau mấy ông có cái chỗ để mà
và tham khảo thôi chứ không phải là leb
vào đây tham khảo tôi không yêu cầu điều
đấy thì đây mày Ông thấy là tại sao tôi
có cái cái bài đăng có thể Mun À nhầm
mày city của bạn đang có nghề nên bởi vì
à mình tí thì mình Phi tôi ấy nhìn fit ở
bên này Mình chọn à là sử là mình chọn
Khanh nhiều cái Kanji đúng không hả nhầm
nhiều cái City có thể hướng thì mình sẽ
kiểm tra là một là City sẽ phải
Westlife đúng với city mình chọn hay là
cái cô City này nó thể nun là được đấy
đây về tôi thấy thử đạt đến mấy ông sẽ
hình dung
em về mình phải inbox lại đã đúng không
ạ sẽ post Ở đây là ở đây này đến onme
mình ạ
về để meepo
ở nhà tôi không báo lỗi gì cả hệ không
bán hàng công nhân sự đá bại cho mẹ
không xem
ai ngờ lên rồi gửi xe
anh không Đây nè
anh gọi lại cho
Ừ mình đang đây Cái gì à
Khi mà mình đang D thằng này sẽ sao lỗi
này tôi sẽ đi đây ngay thôi thêm cả ngày
nữa cụ thể lại sao thằng lỗi
cha mẹ ông nhớ bạ thì ở Lúc mà mình khi
mình khi mình tạo thì mình đâu mặc định
là Jose đi mình nói cho nó vòng một
nhưng mà rõ ràng là thằng tôi lỡ xóa
thật ngu rồi Nãy không có mục user nào
lấy cả đấy ta sẽ thử làm đăng ký đã đăng
ký tài khoản đã rồi tôi sẽ thêm Urê mới
rồi tôi sẽ à Nhưng sẽ tiện thể tôi sẽ
sửa lại toàn bộ mình xin nhà sửa lại
đoạn tất cả đoạn này muốn xin luôn đi
Roy đây để ngoạn
a log in with này bơ tôi sẽ sửa hết bằng
season nhé
Em tắt hết ở ngoài đi ông ấy không đã
xóa đây thì mình cứ làm từ đầu nhé Mình
sẽ có log in đây đã in mặc định sẽ nhảy
nó sẽ
I I love with the weather nó sẽ nhảy
sang bên out này Có bác này đúng không ạ
Có bác mình sẽ làm gì mình sẽ kiểm tra
là đã tồn tại ở chưa đúng không ạ Thế mà
chưa thì sao
tự nhiên đấy nếu mà chưa thì mình lưu
lại này mình đang mặc định là cho màn
amin Thật ra không lên đấy cho mình có
cát ở đây thế này đứng gọn bên mình sửa
lại rồi đây mình sẽ
à à
thì mình sẽ làm việc với sinh gần này
mình sẽ út ở đây
bộ phim sex mút ở đây có những cái gì
mình à
Hình như lại đầu tiên mình đi lại là rô
Cô Nhung ơi tiếp theo là mình sẽ lưu lại
là à
mình nó sẽ là sơ ID lưu lại nêm nữa đúng
không ạ Để mình vì sao dễ đấy à
à à
dung một tí nhé
mô hình nhựa lưu lại trong sân mình như
lại được ghét vì phải đợi lâu một tí này
có Đây ra được xuân tôi muốn lưu lại óc
ngách thằng ngày thay vì cứ lưu lại từng
từng cái như này một để mà tí do lấy từ
season ra cái tôi sẽ gọi một cái phân
tôi tạm một phong trần một cái hopper để
mà lấy kệ đối tượng mà mình đang mình
đang ra
Ừ mình đang đăng nhập là nó dễ hơn nó la
lá giống như mấy ông Hình dung là out
này cùng cái trò là
à cô dâu ngay em ngủ rồi nhỉ lấy đủ rau
nha chẳng hạn thì tôi cũng muốn có một
cái hopper đúng kiểu nhẹ luôn Chào em có
trách đúng như này thì tôi sẽ tạo một
góc chết đi thì ở đây Tôi phải test á
Cái ta sẽ chạy rồi Bên test này mình sẽ
mình sẽ tạo Mình lưu lại season đúng
kiểu ngày nhưng mà
ở nhà bây giờ mình sẽ có một em chat
3 cách khởi tạo ô check trong level hơi
buồn cười lý nữa kiểu như này được
ý là nó sẽ ép mà phải khóc trách như thế
này
ờ ờ
cả ngày chẳng
em thật sự ngay vòng một tháng nó đi lên
này bằng test này chẳng
Sau đó mình sẽ lưu lại ở đây Mình sẽ lưu
lại là và sự là áo đi cũng có áo đi
báo lỗi gì cả mọi ta lại sang bên này
xem bên này có xin nó
tại sao tôi lại muốn làm bạn này đây thì
tôi muốn nó như thế này thôi tôi sẽ tạo
1 Happy để mà lưu lại thằng chó chết này
cơ đi
he he pal thường là mình sẽ dứt trong
cái A một thư mục và hepl
I find tôi tạo hyper cho mấy ông nhờ
chưa Nghỉ trưa mà
có một cái fan xin helper Nếu chưa mà
đúng
em không có không có
sẽ tạo một cái phải một cái thư mục gọi
là Hair như này
à à
à Có sao mình tặng một cái file trong
này
Anh tên là hamper Hoặc cả phương trình
Tùy ông đặt công ty tôi đã đặt tên là
file tên là Phương Trinh nghĩa ngay
chúng tôi về
Ừ mai này đương nhiên phải được lót khi
mà tất cả cốc được chạy và cách để mà
cốt cái xoay này thì đây có thể tham
khảo
Red Pearl còn xịch như thế này em gái
ở chỗ không nhiều lắm Bây giờ tôi cũng
phải tra đấy đây thì thường hay lên có
cấu trúc kiểu ngay là kiểm tra xem Hà đã
tồn tại chưa Nếu chưa thì mình mới khởi
tạo hàm để tránh việc là les hay File
này bị một hai lần gì đó nó bị bị lỗi ấy
sau đó thì phải chèn file này vào trong
cái file autoload
à À đấy nó nằm trong wi-fi trên thế mà
cái đoạn này
nói chung cách Cốt nó sẽ như thế này
và đương nhiên fp rồi à bí
kíp này
nếu mà phẳng trình Note is it ngoại là
nhà mình sẽ Đây là tên lỗi
cài đặt tên Đây là đâu ạ Âu có tồn tại
rồi tôi suy nghĩ tên khác
họ sai
ờ ờ
em ở công ty đạt đúng kiểu Loser nhà
luôn mèo ngoại sẽ đặt kiểu nhà nghỉ Đà
Tăng trưởng ở đây mình sẽ của rousseau
ngay
à à
thì mình sẽ à
khi trở về một giấc mình sẽ Duy Tân
anh
chị nào season II
à mà gọi đến ghét ngọn đèn cao giống như
đúng cái kiểu vừa nãy thôi ở đây nó sẽ
trả về 1 cặp trách ngay
gì Tại sao Và bây giờ cũng có lần tôi
gọi như thế này
Ừ thì nó sẽ
trong nắng xem này
Ừ thì ở sẽ trả về cái mình đang đăng
nhập thôi à mỗi cái hàm này Như Tôi của
Bảo rồi tim mình khởi tạo đây nó chưa
được nói
mình phải xóa mình phải thêm mà trong
cái capo để mà Thì Mở Class cái file đã
chỉnh sửa lại đây con chích này áp
à à
không có râu chưa nhỉ
em không bao giờ này
anh ơi
a cho hỗ trợ thêm một cái đã hết
tule-lost này đặt Autocad Này ông sẽ sửa
lại đây là sẽ chèn thêm một cái file đó
luôn lót
A là a
I find nay sẽ sớm đối ngoại ông sẽ chèn
thêm ở đây cái file của ông
Ừ Ông này viết cái file này nằm trong
cái áp hepl
anh không nhỉ
cái thư mục
Ê bà happel ngay
à à
I have thẻ tổng ra ngoài luôn nhỉ Tống
hẳn ra ngoài đi
xóa mày đi
vì vậy thường chỉ có 1 file helper thôi
áo bóng chuyền này à đ.tp
thought này tất cả cũng chỉ là khi mà
autolike dịch ra nó đúng nghĩa nó nghĩa
tự động loạt trước tất cả những cái
Khoai này mấy ông thấy ra có rất nhiều
cái hàm mà mình gọi giống như chính làm
xét xử như thế này càng ạ đúng ạ Cái này
gọi là Hà p tất cả hàm nó sẽ gọi được ở
bất kỳ đâu đúng ạ Gọi ở trong trong này
mình không cần phải ưu thêm một cái
không cần phải import thêm một cái quý
thì cả bởi cái được lót sẵn rồi cái Hà
được nó sẵn rồi đồng mạng mình có thể
gọi ở trong view cũng được gọi bất kỳ
đâu cũng được thì cái ha Mày gọi là hepl
Tức là nó được lót sẵn được inbox sẵn từ
trước rồi mình chỉ là gọi nó thôi thì
vừa rồi tô vừa ghi thêm một cái phạm mới
này đúng ạ Và tôi muốn cái Hà cũng sẽ tự
động được lót giống như ở đây để mà thay
vì làm sao tôi gọi được ngay sự gọi hàng
này là xong hạ thế thì tôi sẽ phải ghi
vào trong này là tôi phải luôn loát thêm
cái Hà mày được luôn loát file này để
file này gọi đến cái Hàn này thì nó sẽ
như này đấy Ông đã tự tạo cái hấp diêm
không
không sẽ chạy lệnh này để mà xóa cái
autolock đi để còn lại thì thôi
nâng cao lắm nhưng kiến thức này chị
đúng là xịn Junior thì sẽ còn thấy mới
nhưng mà còn mà Tại ông thấy bình thường
để ông ai cũng gọi để lấy Email ngay cả
đấy
thơ Nguyễn à Cái này thì gần như là hồi
đầu tôi mới Tôi mới học lao tội phải
biết qua về mình cái Tôi đoán lên rồi
phải
hay ghi chỗ này
chỗ này à
em
có nếu thấy chưa Bây giờ gọi được đến
cái á hàm xong trên này rồi đến yên tâm
cái này chỉ là một lần thôi có file kia
luôn được bát rồi ông ghi thêm bất kỳ
hàm mới vào trong này thì file luôn đó
rồi nó sẽ gọi được đấy thì bây giờ thay
vì tôi gọi dài dòng season gọi đến thì
bây giờ sẽ chỉ cần gọi tạo một cái ham
học hàm hopper này vào này có thể gọi ở
bất kỳ đâu gọi view gọi bất kỳ đâu được
để mà lấy được cái người dùng hiện đang
đăng nhập hiện tại hiểu cho ông cái
tác dụng của nó
Ở Đây Rồi vừa rồi đi môn thôi Bây giờ
sửa mình sẽ à
A Plus để mà
nó suốt Chẳng có gì cả đúng chưa mình
gọi lại đến sửa mình gọi đến như này thì
rõ ràng trả về cái gì cả sẽ báo lỗi hoặc
sẽ bảo lỗi ơi
Ừ nó bảo Cái lỗi này thì tránh nó vào
cái lỗ này thì mình sẽ mặc định mình sẽ
trả về ờ
anh sex trở về nó luôn nha đi nó sẽ
không
ở đây là khai báo kiểu trở về Vừa nãy
mình phải bảo nó óc rách nhiều thoại
không tồn tại thì mình sẽ trả lời nó
luôn ấy Ok Thế bây giờ tao không có
người nào đăng nhập ngoại bây giờ khi mà
đăng nhập mình sẽ là mình sẽ lưu lại ở
đây Mình sẽ lưu lại là
mình có thể lưu lại khẳng ouzo vào trong
thằng ngày ở công ty tôi thì không nên
lưu lại cả ozo vào trong thằng ngày vì
lưu lại trong thí sinh có quá nhiều
thông tin rồi nó không cần nếu hiểu cho
thì mình là như nêm và ta này rồi đúng
không cần lưu lại email chẳng ạ Đấy Và
khi xếp như này có một điểm rất hay đó
khi chia mà mình thấy báo như này cho
mình xếp lại thì nó sẽ khái niệm là
miệng để tôi thử đoán mình không ông là
đang nghe được nghe thử trả lời nhé Bây
giờ mày Ông thấy là tôi khởi tạo một
tháng mới yêu dâu mới ngày đông ạ đúng ạ
ạ Bây giờ chat chắc chắn nhôm trường mở
máy đang trâu dơ là anh chưa bao giờ cả
đúng không ạ Rồi là chồng đâu ạ Bây giờ
tôi khởi tạo một thằng mới như này thôi
tôi chuyển truyền email và cho nó đúng ạ
đó Xấu dây chuyền mê và Avatar và Grow
cho nó tôi xếp đi lại các bạn trong
trường hợp này trong trường hợp này thì
theo mấy ông
là thằng ngu rô này nó sẽ có đầy đủ tất
cả các cột này
thứ hai là nó chỉ có đúng mỗi bốn cột là
email nên Avatar và đô
em đang chưa có vozer nào đúng ạ lẽ
không có trường hợp và nó sẽ lấy từ tao
bay về mà Đây mình phải tạo thành mới mà
thằng nó trách mới cho mình mình truyền
Nó 44 cột thôi đúng không ạ cho mình xét
lại rồi thì trong trường hợp này thì khi
mình gọi ra nó thì mình sẽ lấy ra được
bốn cột thôi Hay là lấy lại đầy đủ ta
cột
Ừ ông là chuyên Ariel thì không ông làm
tầm một thời gian rồi cũng dễ hiểu cái
này
em thấy cái này khởi tạo đối tượng của
thằng nào nhé Nó là glycine đúng không
theo mấy ông thì nó sẽ trả về bốn cụt
đây sẽ có 3 đã bán cho mấy ông tôi
thường hay cho sinh viên khỏi hỏi sinh
viên cái này
em chưa trắc nghiệm ngay đi mấy ông chơi
cho trắc nghiệm mày đi một là bốn cột
hay là tất cả khu vực
Ý bà là
ừ ừ
nhiều hơn bốn cột nhưng không phải tất
cả
à à 34 là lỗi mẹ tôi thường này sau thêm
cái lỗi
ở đây heo mỳ ông chặt lấy ông thì trả
lời tôi sẽ theo mấy ông thì nó rơi vào
những giờ trường hợp nào
nghĩ nghĩ cho 10 giây nhỉ 3:00
Ừ ông à mà hiểu trả lời đúng con này
chứng tỏ ông đã làm ra đủ lâu rồi đủ mức
là Junior Còn không thì ông ấy mới chịu
phép sơ thôi
anh không chơi tết nha nè
có một bảo 3 Ok
ở nhà ông kia để nè
York chắc chắn nó đang trêu dơ là đúng
không Không lấy được từ tay đúng không
Tôi khởi tạo thằng ngu ra đúng không Nó
truyền và nỗi bốn cột lại email name
avatar Gold xong rồi tôi xếp lại đúng
không cho tôi gọi lại thằng cô dâu thì
treo mấy ông à Thằng ngu rô này nó sẽ
trả về mỗi 4 Cốt và tôi chuyển vào hay
là tất cả các cột ở trong bảng loser
thứ ba là nhiều hơn bốn cột nhưng mà
không phải ta đã cột 4 là nó lỗi
đồ chơi mà mấy ông kia vẫn giữ quan điểm
là bốn con à
có
một ông và giá cột đúng không
Hai ông trời 3
Ok cứ chạy thử nhé
anh nghe thử đăng nhập
cho xem hình Tại sao Lỗi À hôm trước là
tôi đội cái này 170
U21 27
bên kia phải sửa lại
à à
nó trả về nhiều hơn bốn cột và cũng
không đầy đủ là cột tại sao cái này đủ
các bạn nắm rõ hơn đó là có những cột nó
sẽ mặc định tự động điền cái này theo cơ
chế của Lara Cái này nó không nó không
lấy từ tao bay về hãy nhiều điều nó
không đầu tư đã lâu với thứ duy nhất vào
lấy chính của ai đi thôi Tại để vào nó
cái lấy cột ID này thì thằng mai que vào
cơ chế là Insert get ID nên thành nha nó
sẽ lấy được gọi đi về đây chưa Còn những
cái cột khác thì nó không lấy về cho rồi
kể cả cho dù cuộc đời có cái defoe là
bao nhiêu bao nhiêu nữa nó không tự động
lại về nhưng mà hai cái này là thằng leo
nó tự động điên nếu mà ông để kỹ là hồi
đầu mình đã có cái khai báo ở đây em mặc
định nếu không khai báo thì mình có cái
trường timestamp bằng Chu Tước à là hai
cái này nó sẽ tự động Điền và đương
nhiên mặc định là nó sẽ kiểu sẽ là kiểu
hai cái bằng nhau vì thế mới mà nó bằng
nhau thì thôi
anh ấy ba bây giờ thế nên là trong một
vài trường hợp đó nếu ông sẽ thắc mắc là
nếu mà em muốn lấy tất cả cột về thì sao
thì mình sẽ phải dùng cái hàng này nữa
nó Hà mà web và flash thì phải phát lại
như Xóa toàn bộ đi phát là đệ mà họ sẽ
sẽ cậu à đây
thì nó sẽ cầu gọi lại từ đầu tới bây lấy
về toàn bộ thông tin trong trường hợp
như là nếu Bông lấy toàn bộ thông tin nó
sẽ như thế này
a tiếp theo là bây giờ như tôi đã bảo
tôi muốn lưu lại trong sân cái thằng ngu
rồi chẳng hạn thì một cách là tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi có thể là chị lấy cái trường mà
tao muốn lấy sẽ là như thế này cả ở
Ừ cái này không ở trên tài liệu đâu chơi
không Không có trên tài liệu nên tôi sẽ
thử xem cái thằng là là quần thử xem có
những cái hàm gì của nó quên sửa
Ừ em anh chị muốn lấy nó với nhau của
access 2 only nhờ tôi nhớ có hạ Moly vậy
à à
Ừ
chị lấy những cái thứ tôi muốn lấy đó là
anh hai đi ngoại
A và
cố lên
ở Quy Nhơn
Ừ thế thôi đó sau đó cho tôi sẽ lưu nó
lại
ở đâu không ạ
chỉ có mình sẽ lưu lại như này Ok chưa
cô dâu tại sao lôi ở đây nhỉ
à à Vừa nãy có cá rô đã này đúng không ạ
anh vẫn cần rô để mà trả về
lại đến nhảy đến cái tương ứng
xe chạy hơn
Ừ thôi sẽ thử Return hàng cái thằng à
anh ở đây đang đi đích rồi nha
ẩm thực dê xin thằng à khu rừng U ready
a cho mình xem nhé
ăn mì đây
Return về Ừ ok ok
ở khách sạn Royal nhỉ
anh cho xem
Vứt vào trong thằng à
cả ngày luôn đi Mệt quá
à à
cho
thuê loa sân không trả lời gì này
khi những chuyên đội ngũ giờ đây này à
e sẽ có mấy thằng nó trách à
E bằng à
đây sẽ là
chế độ Giờ này có bị đoạn này nhá
Ở đây có một Android ở đây bằng toàn bộ
này ngon
em ngủ trưa sau đó thì ở đây mình chỉ
cần assistant à
à season food
anh ở đây mình sẽ Ép kiểu nó thành nắp
check
kiện ở đây là được cái xong
à Xong rồi
a ly ở đây rồi
a7r mình chỉ có dám gọi lại cái Hàn này
cho mình
ở đâu ra sao
à à
Và như thế tôi có xưởng slot để xóa toàn
bộ à
anh Alo chắc là mình phải có cái mô tơ
lockout mày nghỉ chưa có đấy có mà nhé
có ai ở đây là đâu nào
theme flash thôi
thì mình sẽ ở đây
nhỉ
khi đăng nhập nha xong rồi mày đi lại
đồng với người dùng đã đăng nhập
chị Hồng đã
họa xịn
sẽ
A gọi đến hàng nhái nói user sạc cô đơn
giản
luôn
đăng nhập Nga quay lại bên này thì nhé
lại quay lại bài toán bên này khi mình
import đúng không Thì mình inbox à
là mình sẽ
đi xóa lại đi
thế này sẽ là nhìn là nhìn nhìn cái cục
này sẽ là Loser gọi đến nay đi
sao thật đơn giản bởi thằng ngày nào
check trả về nhà xong lại
Ừ nó đâm chết
xu hướng giờ có mà
em yêu
anh ơi
Ừ biết rồi
Âm Nhạc
phụ đề
nhóm rồi nhỉ
a good
cho tao mượn anh em à
I have rồi để em ạ đăng nhập lại này
anh đi
đã sửa một đống xong lại lỗi I hear the
season tôi có khi lại chuẩn bị chết rồi
vớ vẩn
à à
Em sang bên này mất luôn à
từ ngày đầu tiên ozer có một người đúng
không
anh mất tuổi xuân của tôi gọi vãi chưởng
cho xem
Khi anh nhảy sang Daughter mới là cái
shinto start nhỉ
Chỉ có mày nghỉ sẽ tắt đi nhỉ
em
ở đâu rồi đấy
Ừ cứ bỏ xuân của tôi có vấn đề
Season trên máy thôi Nhưng tối Đây Rồi
anh admin
chú thích
anh không có nên không có đi được nghe
gì cả
a a đây phải còn miss the west Texas
không ạ đậu xanh
Ừ chắc thế cho Thế có cả thấy mấy anh
nha
Ừ thôi nhá
a web này
không được được thì đúng buồn cười Luôn
Đúng
ý nghĩa là có khi là toàn bộ mấy hôm
trước làm cái Âu
đó là do mình chưa có species in không
làm được Au
hình như thế đấy để thử Pháp
Ừ
nhưng mà trò hề vậy
à à
đầu
ở đây tiền mình knockout nhớ
lắm rồi có lát ở đây rồi nhớ vẫn chưa
Xóa đi Đúng rồi có ra đây rồi Chứ ở
trong sân khấu rồi lưu lại trong rừng
ngay chắc chắn ơi cũng chưa Star Season
đấy đúng rồi đúng rồi đúng rồi đúng rồi
đúng rồi
ở đây đây đây đây đây chứ còn đâu nữa
có ai trồng khoai đất này
anh bảo sao hôm trước gọi gọi ao vỡ mồm
ở trong cái thằng biết được mẹ không gọi
được ở nhà
anh alo
anh yên tĩnh
cô gái ở đây báo chưa
a lô
đ.d Daewoo ở đây luôn đi
Mệt mỏi quá đi
à à
gì đã ạ
Ừ Ok Sang đây Lại không có gì à
A gọi hay biết the well này không được
à à
để tránh bị có bị đục như này tuổi Chơi
trò đu quay cầu này đi
Ừ mình đang gọi ở đây
Ê hồi trước tôi ta làm kiểu như này
á hậu
đâu đấy
đâu này
Ừ tao thay nó là ăn Min
cái là
trại rồi nhỉ
Anh nhớ là thằng web và luôn để phố chạy
không cần phải khai báo rồi em nhỉ
về chưa
a web novel Matter Where I
nghĩa là mình mình khai báo ở trong
thống web này là tất cả những thằng khác
nó sẽ chạy qua thằng web rồi nghỉ à
thế đâu
tác giả rotor the way này nói chuẩn
bộ phim xã La
em ăn mini
thì mình sẽ là ờ
em có ý cái này
có vitamin the way bảo nó là ăn Minh ơi
ở đây đây
ừ ừ có vẻ hợp lý lợi tình yêu đợi tí nha
tí nữa này tôi chạy được
lại quay lại bên nhau
anh vẫn lỗi cái rồi
đây ông nhá
đi học nó không hề chạy vào cái step
ở season
ờ ờ
What should i
vì
nó không chạy vào cái cái này luôn
khai báo như này
the weather
I work group này
start ajisen này đã kéo hiểu cho
mình mới dùng được Ảo đúng không hợp lý
mà hợp lý mà
thuần đó nha Cái chỗ khác đấy
ô tô xe máy
I miss virus này
dùng mấy cái dưỡng mình không chúng
way là cái này kê vứt kiến em trong này
âm nhạc Nhưng mà thường là chẳng ai Vứt
vào trong này
Ừ Thôi mình cứ viết ở trong này không
sao chắc không sao đâu
có
ai trồng khoai đất này đấy lên lạnh alo
chị sẽ
a cho chị con
có gì này 22
ở đó xin hai Arsene
chỉ cần mình có áo rồi
anh không cần cái ai nữa ngồi
ừ ừ
sát season này của tôi chỉ mới siren xác
sẽ dần này có thể dùng ngay từ lúc đầu
bởi vì à mình còn làm cho cả thằng nấu
kết mà Mấy ông nhớ không đấy Không cần
phải là vụ đấy
em dậy dậy dậy sẽ
cô nhóc con
à huhu
nghe thấy gì à À đây thì tôi sẽ vứt cái
này vào trong thằng à
phóng sinh mới mình làm quen không -
đúng không sẽ à
a retro
ở bài thi
Có ai này mình sẽ xuyên cái này vào
chị đã được
để trả luôn trả về string
Ừ
cái này sẽ là
ờ ờ trên Woa đôla ozer vào
Ừ biết rồi 7 kì II
nhớ ngủ sớm đó
em trả lời cá rô như thế này
khi quét quét lấy zô nào
chị Hà Ru Alo số Alo số bến xe là
a Hero Wiki
cô gái sẽ là
in game dễ
ở đây sẽ ra
Em đổi cái này trở lại cũ có như chưa
từng có cuộc chia ly ngày sau A
nhập xong phải nhảy ra cái Trang
ờ ờ
a plan
Ông xã biết rồi nhỉ
à Hôm trước mình làm cái gì mà biết rồi
nhỉ
mà đang đăng nhập mình đăng ký
Ừ thì sẽ lại
AE đăng nhập rồi
thì sợ đăng ký à
Đó là hình hôm đấy là đang ở hôn đẩy em
mặc định để sao không đăng kí vậy
đâu mà mình nhận nó
anh xóa sử là mày đi
anh
là mày nha
à à
3:00
ở đâu Ở đây
đề thi đi đặt tên này kia đi
trí này
đã
sửa tên cái này tí
ở chỗ này Loki
ở nhà shiroki à
khi đăng nhập nhập Lucky user
ok này đăng nhập Sorry lyrics về trang
web này
Thì mẹ sẽ luôn Quy định này đây này sẽ
là cho đến logo của nó lấy được Loki
Đăng nhập đăng nhập vào quá xịn
cho chị xin
Em thử lại biết à ngắm ảnh cái ta đã ok
lệ theo có thêm động lực ra ngắm em
Không anh quay lại bài toán đăng nhập
khi đăng nhập lại nha
I know Tao đi
không đúng chứ
khi đăng nhập
như này đúng không
Hồ Ngọc Hà phát nữa
thường nhỉ
AE nhập bình thường mình làm chưa nhỉ
Ừ hình như mình còn chưa làm vụ đăng
nhập bình thường
nó không ý nghĩa gì đấy cả chúng ta mùa
nào đăng nhập bằng tài khoản Hay là đăng
ký không nói chuyện Đăng nhập tài khoản
bình thường nữa bởi vì nó có bán buôn
đâu
Anh
đang ở bình thường à
mình nhảy hẳn
Anh Bình cho đăng nhập bằng máy nút này
luôn đi đơn giản đi dăm ba cái password
bằng đúng mỗi cái mạng xã hội thôi sẽ
hội đúng không Bỏ qua Bỏ qua
khi đăng nhập đúng mà mỗi này thế cho
nhà đỡ xử lý gì cả đời có đăng ký a ghi
đang cục sót
chuyến lại thôi
Phèo rỡ đơn giản quá hợp lý
anh em
ừ ừ
khi đăng nhập
Ừ ok
lại quay lại vụ bài đăng ở
lấy từ đâu thì sẽ là sẽ là Wow gọi đến
Có ai đi ghét idea Không ai đi thẳng
luôn á Alo nhầm
Ừ hình như này được nghe đó
đi xe hàm viết tắt của nó để gọi ozo gọi
ai đi mà
Ông chủ nhà thử nhận biết được
em có cuốc đây đi cái nắp PIN thật không
được trả góp
anh phải gọi phát này nữa
như này
rồi
ạ bây giờ chán lắm
Tối mới kiểu nhà em bởi vì à Chắc là
người dùng có rất loại nhiều đâu mà
người loại người dùng 3 có 3 loại người
dùng mình gọi Gác đầy đủ nhưng mà
khi tôi bắt đầu thích quay lại bên Xuân
nói
chia tay
à à
ừ ừ
em
mệt mỏi thế nhỉ
[âm nhạc]
làm cả ngày đi làm được rồi
Anh sợ chồng mấy
[âm nhạc]
xem à
em
trả về đúng cái thằng đấy
Cho tôi xin phép
a z xem lại cái đoạn ở công ty tôi làm
cái đoạn này nó nghe nó lôgic như nào
Phát
anh kể cái đoạn này tôi thấy là nó lằng
nhằng quá
ế quá mức cô nhà mạng này luôn
à à
Ừ
đúng rồi gửi đi trước làm cái loạn này
đỡ nặng
ô ô là Loan đã làm đoạn này phức tạp Vãi
cả chưa
gọi đến đó
ở đài Viettel ouzo Ngày mai đi đúng
không Tôi đang định làm ngay đây sẽ
Return à
ờ ờ
ở
đâu News
anh luôn
khi sex
à à
công ty tôi không làm Các công ty tôi
dùng cá rô permission Ồ vãi chưởng
Maria Tại sao nghỉ tại sao mình lại dùng
Plus nhỉ
chai á dở được
bằng cách này
đó
vì mình lưu lại ở trong nhà
Ừ cái này đi lại gác ngay
cách làm bài toán bị phức tạp hóa
mấy ông đã nhận được bài học xương máu
ở Samsung Galaxy cả cả các cung gì nữa
đây nữa cả
cách xóa các đi
cho tỷ lệ tí nhá
Ờ Nami này bọn gái teen
users anh anh đúng không ạ
rồi nha
à à
love Channel đây Tại sao phải Schannel
bởi vì ạ
chỉ có thể là thằng ngu giờ này là con
chưa đăng nhập
anh sẽ gọi hành khách
từ ngày kiểm tra xem đã
em không có lùn
dung nhé
la la cao này
nữa Tôi không phải mày Đố vào đúng rồi
Nếu mà chưa đăng nhập này
anh hoặc
em là thơ
A gọi đến zô
óc ở đây không không trả về
không trả về ô check thì đương nhiên là
là trong trở về luôn nó sẽ bị báo lỗi
thôi
e-zone
à à
trước chứ đăng nhập như lai giữa xử đã
khi họ ok rồi này
đang ám in rồi nên nó đâu vào ngoại
cho tôi thử thai nó là hết rồi thì cũng
sẽ thấy là nó sẽ không được vào
Ừ nó ok chị chưa rồi đấy rồi anh rosie
cái này về ôn lại
đậu xanh thắm Luyện ăn gì này đó sau đó
ở bên này xong hết rồi xong hết đau đầu
quá không có vát cùng gì đấy nữa là sau
bên này khi mình sẽ chỉ có chỉ cần gọi
cô dâu nha Ai đi sau A
mở mã PIN boot được
anh nghe được đấy về nhà lỗi Pháp vì lỗi
này lỗi liên quan đến bảo file mà không
liên quan
gì đấy
tự hào mua fire mình cũng à anh cũng có
cái lỗi tương tự nó đây truyền vào như
này sẽ đổ đầy Loser trả lời ID sao nhẹ
nhàng
Ừ mình ở đó Hà Nội Hồ Chí Minh Hà Nội
thì hơi hồ chí minh luôn này tớ làm chị
hoàn toàn thể truyền Thêm vào
cho Thái Tổ nhiều em biết khỏi cho thay
trâu nhiều là cái gì
không buồn cười rồi thì sau Ờ
vani ID là nun thức À không nhưng sẽ
được còn bên đây này
thì tại sao của kompany nuôi lại đây nhỉ
Ừ ừ nhớ có một con bên này thì thôi
chồng vì vậy Ngon tiếp theo canxi Việt
Nam Việt Nam Việt Nam ok rồi tại Music
có vẻ là ôi có một hành vi most people
này bởi vì ạ
Anh tên của cái địa điểm nó remote nó
remote Apple thì thôi lại
Ừ ok chưa lên ngờ Cuối cùng thì mình tự
nhiên mình khỏe bài toán về Woo cũng
cung hôm nay vẫn chưa làm được cái gì cả
nhưng mà tổng kết Hôm nay thì mấy ông
thầy đó là cách tôi xử lý nó sẽ ra
khi tổng hợp lại nha nó dễ hiểu nha Nhìn
đống file nhìn choáng ơi nó tiên à À
nhầm nhầm nhầm nhầm rồi
ờ ờ web môi giới
ngắn hơn tí đầu tiên à Có tôi chỉ mới
ông bằng cách tạo hyper không ạ
để tạo một file autoload ngoại
sửa lại cái bên out xóa xóa đăng ký đi
hôm sau sẽ xóa hàng đăng ký đi không làm
việc với rô là không làm việc Glass nữa
mình sẽ đăng nhập ngao rồi ngay cái quan
trọng cái bài toán
chút kinh nghiệm ở đây đó là mình sẽ
phải Star cái sừng trước thì mình mới có
thể dùng our nhọn nên là mình tôi đã
Tống Xá season lên trên cùng của thẩm mỹ
được quen nghĩa luôn luôn chạy qua Hàng
ngày trước khi làm mọi thứ đấy bởi vì
mình dùng
localization tức là làm cái trang bằng
nhiều ngôn ngữ thế này là kiểu gì mình
cũng cần xin nó phải lo understand đấy
Đúng rồi trước đây dạo này hơi lừa chứ
không to unpack của mình chẳng liên quan
gì cả khoa học đợi ông nào ngồi làm sửa
lại cái mục đầu thôi chứ Đó là tiêu đề
hay lửa
tiếp theo là tôi chỉ bị ông về việc à
i m the weather weather thực ra mình có
thể chuyển rô ở đây được cũng không hồi
trước tôi định làm mấy chuyện dù ở trong
này xong rồi trả về thì nó nhanh hơn như
thể làm vụ đấy nhưng hệ lô từ đây Được
Hay vì mình cứ phải truyền và kiểu ngay
cái để cho xe ấy ngồi sửa lại cách lấy
này gà cốt khi đẩy lên không nên bao giờ
được để d không em qua mình đang chạy
trên local để đê thôi thường mình thì
trả lại bảo lỗi cho người dùng mà kiểu
đê vui như thế này lại
à à
buổi I
Em out
thường theo cái e này hát hepl
Ừ có gì nhỉ
Ừ ừ mày mỗi thế thôi
con gà còn thêm cả mycocin Bây giờ bé bỏ
qua
kể khúc nhạc ngoại
Ừ có gì thì à mai thì à Tôi tôi à
Anh ở mai tôi sẽ chấm cá nhóm đông ạ Và
tôi sẽ chữa cho các và có nhiều nhóm như
cần chữa nhà tôi cứ thông báo lại trong
béo mà thống nhất à cứ thứ bảy tôi sẽ
chữa cho tất cả các nhóm và nhóm là cần
hỗ trợ thì sau buổi loài chim vì có thể
chữa loạn chứ không Tôi khó mà chửa Nói
chung là trừ khi mấy nhóm cần gấp lắm
thì tôi mới chữ ở trong tuần thôi bây
giờ trong tuần Tuy khá bận
và chính xác làm mai từ ngày kia gọi khá
bận Sáng thứ bảy chủ nhật tôi vẫn còn là
phải lên trường ạ thì sao
em tin anh Tuấn Hiệp ở bắt đầu phải đến
trường học offline
Ừ nhưng mà lại chỗ mà Thứ Bảy Chủ nhật
này thì ra tối ra bận từ 8 giờ sáng đến
5 giờ chiều về mà ngồi lên trường khác
em yên tâm tôi vẫn sẽ ở
em hết tâm còn trọng nhất ở cái tâm từ
trước này thực là điều mà tôi muốn nói
mấy ông ấy đó là mấy ông phải nhiều lúc
là tôi dậy nó có vấn đề thật có hơn Đây
là khó lúc giống như hai bữa rồi nha Ừ
rồi Vận Chuyển 2 tuần chẳng hạn mãi chưa
xong được cái A không ạ nghĩa nghĩa là
có thể chưa chuẩn bị bài kỹ cũng cũng
thể dùng từ đấy đúng và đứng nhờ chủ nào
thì phải mắc sai lầm tôi vẫn tôi tôi vẫn
vẫn thường hay nói thế nhưng mà cũng
không thể phủ nhận được và để lỗi của
tôi khi mà nó chưa chuẩn bị bài kỹ vân
vân gì cả chứ chưa nghiệp hay gì đó
nhưng mà tôi thích kiểu đấy Nó là kiểu
chỉ cho mấy ông cách giải quyết khi mà
tôi gặp vấn đề gì đó con gà đấy cũng
mang tính chất là gọi là mỹ viện là
nhiều thôi nhưng mà cái
không phải mấu chốt ở đây Tôi muốn nói
nó là
Anh không quan trọng với việc cái dậy
lắm mà quan trọng nhất về cái tâm và cái
và cái mục đích
Ừ thứ nhất là người dạy phải có tâm
có rất nhiều thầy cô dạy cái tâm nữa họ
bị mất rồi cho dù là họ rất là chuyên
nghiệp như họ không hề có tâm đã dạy họ
dậy hơi hồi thạch cao vật tôi thì theo
đỡ nhờ tôi thì con điểm đổi tôi thì tôi
vẫn thấy à cái tâm mình đang vẫn đúng
Vẫn kiểu vẫn khi lọc các thứ thứ hai cái
thứ nhất thứ 2 đó là về
tôi tôi tôi muốn hiểu Mục tiêu của tôi
muốn tốt cho mấy ông chứ không phải là
vì vì thêm một cái gì cả mọi cái tội
thấy rất là nhiên khi mà kênh lên đến
10.000 để mà tôi vẫn chưa biết được là
nên tổ chức một cái gì hay ở
Ừ tôi vẫn thẳng nhiên ấy không hiểu lấy
10.000 cho à Bởi vì thứ ba đang ở trong
đầu tiên công ty thì kiểu gì có rất
nhiều Anh em vào ủng hộ nhưng mà thực ra
anh em cứ để cùng xem tình hình hơi sợ
hai mấy người nữa và nói chung là cái
việc mình người xem nữa video bởi bị vô
lý rồi nhá
Nhưng mà đại khái thì
ờ ờ
Ừ chắc là tôi sẽ có một cái gì đó cậu
buổi
ờ ờ mái tóc đây à Ừ thế vậy anh em ở
Nói chung trước mắt thì vẫn ở Hồ Chí
Minh đi còn sau đó thì ở Đà Nẵng với Hà
Nội Cha sau sẽ có gì gặp anh em song
hoặc hoặc là ở Hà Nội thì cho tôi sẽ ưu
tiên nào sau cái đồ bảo vệ đồ án thì anh
em mình sẽ gặp gỡ Bởi vì tôi ở Hà Nội mà
sẽ gặp gỡ trước
Em ở chỗ nào cả đấy Tùy mọi người
Ừ Tự nhiên hôm trước có người còn bảo
với tôi là
nhà em có trong nhóm Zalo trong đấy có
nhiều người biết đến thầy em quý thầy
lắm những nhà nghiên ạ đây với tôi không
biết mấy ông ấy nào nha Tôi cảm thấy tôi
nhỏ bé thế nên khi mà ra ngoài đường về
tôi cảm thấy tôi nhỏ bé thật không phải
dạng gần như là cậu mấy mấy Chim nổi
tiếng kiểu ra ngoài đường có người ở A
anh đấy à các kiểu thứ họ không bất ngờ
lắm Còn tôi vẫn rất là bất ngờ khi mà
cũng bất kỳ ai và với anh vòng đấy à
Mình hiểu anh cố nhớ xem là mình gặp
người này vợ chưa chứ không bở nghĩ việc
à Mình người nổi tiếng có người biết đến
mình cả Thế à
đồ án hay Hi vọng không Toàn tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ Cậu đăng lên sport rồi anh em
nào nó thấy đi được thì đi một buổi
offline nho nhỏ ở Hà Nội Nếu có thể nhỉ
Đấy chắc là thế thôi
Khi bữa mày trai thế nhỉ Có gì nói cho
mấy ông xem bất kỳ chỗ đoạn nào Tao thấy
khó quá thì xem lại mà vẫn chưa hiểu thì
hãy nhắn tôi nhắn tin cho anh hoặc bình
luận sau nhá Chồng mấy ông nhé